my guest tonight is a very funny
comedian who starred in the king of
queens
and kevin can wait his new series the
crew
is streaming right now on netflix please
welcome
kevin james how are you kevin i'm doing
great i'm doing okay
how are you doing are you are you all
right i'm losing it a little bit
you know uh well you can relate because
you did stand up for years and uh you
always
you did a show in front of a crowd this
is a strange time
um we're all doing the best we can i see
that you're in a room and they took your
furniture away
you know everything everything was gone
it's all been locked down on quarantine
i'm not allowed to quarantine with
furniture i'm not allowed to be a
furniture it's not in my bubble
just looking at you it looks like all
your stuff got repossessed
that like you you made some bad
investments and they came and took
everything covered and quarantined came
with
a a need for something to do and that
turned into gambling and that turned
into some
some bad decisions and yeah i'm glad
that you chose
this show as a place to talk about this
openly yes people really go
i am the oprah of of late night uh no
wait
am i right you are not living in you're
living in florida now
is that right i'm in florida now well
i'm part-time both i'm splitting but i
got out of there with the snow and uh
it was crazy uh by the way down here in
florida it's
people going around like nothing's going
on i mean it's it's
right it's insane so they're they're
acting like
covet's not a problem nothing yeah you
know i mean
you know it's it's mass but they seem to
be okay i don't know right i think when
you
wear a thong to work it's probably hard
to talk someone into wearing a mask do
you know what i mean
it's true you're not covering the other
end
why would you care about it yeah do you
like
i have to tell you i would have a hard
time in florida this is just me
because uh humidity i don't do great
with humidity
my hair collapses i get depressed what
about you
by the way my body looks like it
wouldn't do well with humidity and it
doesn't do well with humidity
but i love it i crave it i don't know
why i um
i like tropical that's why i didn't like
la i was in la for a long time i didn't
like it
right and uh i'll sit in my car when
it's hot
and like i won't even turn it on for
like a little sauna i don't know why i
like it i
i i'm drawn to it maybe it's just my
way of bringing on sweet death yeah yeah
please
uh you can go to a real sauna you don't
have to sit
in a hunt in a hyundai with the windows
closed in florida
there's a better way to do it uh were
you when you lived here you mentioned
you lived here in l.a
some people get freaked out they don't
want to live in l.a because you're
worried about
uh the earthquakes my wife really
paranoid about earthquakes
so we live out here i don't think about
it she thinks about it all the time
whenever we have one she freaks out did
you do okay with that when you lived
here
no i didn't because um here's
you get a hurricane you can see it
coming it's that whole lack of control
thing
i think when i was uh in la i had
a couple little rumbles and i'd never
experienced anything like you didn't
like it before so i felt completely out
of control the whole place is swinging a
little you know yeah
and i freak out and i overreact to every
little one now you know like
so i didn't like it at all it wasn't
like i would act like it was the
one in 94 right and it would just be a
little shimmer and
and i go crazy honestly i just ripped my
shirt off and i would run outside i
don't know the rules by the way i don't
know what you're supposed to do
no well let me tell you something no one
says take your shirt off in an
earthquake and run outside that's not
one of the no one says to do i think it
is i think it would find the door jamb
then take your
door jamb the door jam i've heard no one
i've never there's no i don't see take
your shirt off anywhere on this blank
blue card
all right head between the legs take
your shirt off i don't know when anyway
my shirt was off that sounds erratic
yeah yeah at least you're having a good
time even if the world's freaking
what about so you mentioned hurricanes
hurricanes because i grew up on the east
coast and there'd be a hurricane coming
when i was a kid
i get kind of i know they're dangerous i
get kind of excited when a hurricane
comes yes it's that you want to go out
in the storm hold on to the pole and see
how long you can
you know get blown away but it doesn't
matter yeah
i i i don't know why because of the fact
that you know
you can see it happening and you can
kind of feel it and you know it's gonna
pass and
there is an excitement there's a
challenge to it in a way yeah that i'm
okay with
yeah and you can yeah you can take some
action you can go out and get some
lanterns
you can get a raincoat i don't know
there's some stuff you can do you can
put something over the windows
earthquake what are you gonna do there's
nothing just take your shirt off and run
outside
with that being said i haven't been in
any thank god any devastating
hurricanes which i you know you can
imagine not as fun not good
not good uh you have four kids
four this is just a test i like to
randomly ask celebrities if they
remember how many children they have you
have
yeah and four yeah are they
fans of your comedy that's i asked that
and i asked that because
i will go first to put the shame on me
my kids
not interested in my work at all in a
way that i find
my daughter's 17 my son's 15. uh not
that interested and i show him something
they're like
all right move it along old man and yeah
it's very humbling how are you doing
with that it was the same thing i think
i came out of the box hot
like they liked me like right away
and then uh it faded quick like and and
i think
my kids are very smart and they did and
i like that it faded quick kind of
because
yeah yeah you can tell they don't love
my stuff
and like they don't like the big broad
you know they don't like mall cop very
they liked it and when it came out but
my oldest one is like
why do you why why do you fall down why
are you falling down so much
you know she would be like that i'm like
well it's kind of you know for the kids
and the fact you know and
yeah it's just a kind of a big fun broad
comedy right and she's like
but really like i mean how many times do
you really need to and i was like i
don't know i guess
i didn't maybe it is a lot i don't know
and she had me thinking
it's really a lot and i'm like all right
yeah maybe you're
you know that's when you need to bring
up stuff like box office
yes um you like that bike you're riding
this that
mall cop paid for that you want to hand
it back that's
that's when i if they go too far i start
to bring up you know this
this is paying for stuff okay exactly so
yeah
it may not be high art but you got to
shut up
somebody finds it to be high art okay
yeah
back at that or nobody does but it seems
to be doing well yeah
are you uh how are you doing are you
taking care of yourself are you
you know because this is a time when a
lot of people can
man i know for myself i
uh i usually try to stay pretty active
and
during especially these late stages of
covid i can notice i think i've been on
this couch
for like 11 hours straight yeah and
i haven't i'm not even reading a book
i'm just lying here
staring at the molding on the ceiling
how are you doing with the whole thing
um
it's the same thing and i'm i really
made a conscious effort like when when
covert hit when we were on the
quarantine on lockdown
i was adamant about not letting this get
the best of me like i was like i was
gonna be one of the few that came out of
this thing
like better than he went in and it's
like wow look what kevin james did man
look how ripped he is like he got like
he just completely reinvented his career
he's just on top of the world and that
was it i was like i'm gonna shock people
they're not gonna know i'm gonna have a
different look and
about day three that was that was out
so two days you got two days of that two
full days of it i was locked in
something threw me i don't know what it
was but it was oh somebody brought over
a lasagna
and then it just didn't
it didn't pan out and now it's like it's
exactly that it's gotten to the point
where you
i've got to do something now so but
it's you know i tried to do the things
because the workouts have changed now
you can't go to the gyms anymore or you
know
yeah so i would do uh i looked at
peloton i wanted to do that
oh that's very that's been very popular
during quarantine yeah that's what i
thought yeah so everybody was doing that
and i looked into it and then i
i checked out some of the workouts on
that and they're brutal they're really
hard
i mean uh so i didn't like that i would
look for the easiest workout like and
then i would look for the guy who looks
like he would make the easiest workout
just so i could keep up and then even i
couldn't find anybody there
basically i was just looking for a guy i
don't know
maybe just a guy sitting on a stationary
bike watching tv with me
[Laughter]
it just felt like it was like yeah why
does the person need to be moving
yeah i'm with you on that just a person
who's on the bike
but with a really big wide seat not
moving
maybe enjoying you know some fried rice
and well that would be the part that
pissed me off the most when they would
everybody up stand up why are we
standing up
standing up on your bikes you know it's
like it was just too much yeah so i was
just kind of i i stopped
very very early on realizing i was just
looking for a friend and just
get out of it are you able to go to any
doctor's appointments i don't think i've
seen
anybody you know this whole time i've i
thought i don't want to go to a doctor's
office so no i haven't gotten checked
out i've got lumps
everywhere like i got i've got things
i've got to do
i haven't my dentist you know the
dentist cleaning i'm so afraid of it now
it's been because it's supposed to be
like six months you go every two you
know
yeah they were going on a year now year
and day like
i don't even know it's like i'm afraid
to do that the whole checkup thing get
cleaning and
i don't like when they do the uh i hate
it when they
i always feel like i'm just not prepared
and they do the gum check
yeah you do that yeah yes they do they
they check your gums to make sure that
you're flossing
your gums are healthy and i don't you
know i'm not ever ready for that
never and they give numbers and the
numbers the higher the number
the worse you're doing and you feel
crappy about yourself and
you're like oh three two oh good you
feel good and then it's it's like
gambling and then it's like oh a five
five five that whole part of your jaw is
just rotting out
yeah no i've had that where i actually
think right now because you go i go
you know whatever once twice a year and
they scrape the tartar off your enamel
i think the tartar after a year of not
being scraped is holding my teeth
together
without a doubt and i think my gums are
gone and i just have
tartar holding the teeth that's what's
locked it all in at this point
with that once they remove the barnacles
and all that stuff
there's no barnacles in there it's
something it's very thick
cement uh let's talk about the crew a
very funny show and a great
idea because it's set in the world of
nascar
and um it really which is
a hugely popular part of
america you know and americana and
um so it seemed to me like it was a good
decision to set it there and your
character
it feels like this gives you an
impression to kind of
try different things you know what i
mean like you've been you've been
working a couple of impressions in there
every now and then yeah uh
this is i'm not great at impressions but
one of my uh co-workers did a uh
so i had to pull out in the de niro
impression right away
because just just the phase
yeah i'm not good at impressions i don't
have do you have impressions i don't do
i mean i do cartoony impressions over
the years
of certain people like for years i would
do schwarzenegger years and years ago
and then i realized it's basically uh a
dictator ranting
um and it sounds like he has sausage in
his mouth
but do you do any of your friends
because i know you and ray romano were
tight and everybody
i had a little bit of a rocky for a
while rocky balboa
the the rocky balboa which everybody had
just dipped my own you know
it was all that stuff right but what i
like is i have a mickey
with you yeah mickey trainer no
everyone does rocky no one does mickey
yeah let me try to do a mickey okay
are you you [ __ ] bombs into your
fight oh crap
lightning yeah yeah you must be in that
body
you're fighting you're correct
[Laughter]
you have to yeah between him and
stallone you you need subtitles to know
what's going on
that's very good
that's very good the thing i don't i
don't do a ray romano impression but the
thing i've noticed about him is that for
a guy who's had so much
success in his life it hasn't changed
him at all
and he's just and he's always just kind
of ah
yeah yeah and and i don't know
ah and every time i see him i'm like
right it's good to see you it's so good
ah it's a sunny day i could rain soon
[Music]
that's like i don't know yeah
yeah personified yeah he's he's amazing
you can't you can't you you won't get to
talk very much uh
into a conversation you'll get deep into
it without him bringing up a skin
tag or uh
you're like all right well things are
good right yeah you're doing it right
yeah yeah
but come on you know it's like
how many years could i have left uh
so you play uh in in the crew you're the
the crew chief
of this nascar racing team so uh and and
and what's again what's nice is it's a
good ensemble piece
because it's it it works into the show
very nicely that there's a bunch of
people you have to work with
and so you get these great characters
involved and i would imagine also
uh you get you get to have some real
nascar personalities come in
without a doubt yeah we've had ryan
blaney and uh cole custer and these guys
are great they're great actors too which
which annoyed me honestly they were very
funny when they came on the set
that's the one of the benefits of being
having nascar behind you you know so
you're not doing
smash car you know where you're kind of
making up this world
they give you everything they give you
cars we've had the drivers and
and all that but uh the the key to it is
man is the cast of this one for me
because i mean i've done domestic
comedies before and this is a workplace
comedy which is different for me
but the ball man you can dish the ball
to them and they're just fantastic
they're just so great they're young
good funny they they really pissed me
off in a way because they are
so good like i thought i'd be the old
guy kind of giving them the tips of a
sitcom how a sitcom works and all this
stuff and they're they're really they're
much better than i ever was so
it's it's it's a pleasure to share this
i can relate to that i get really
irritated when
uh really good-looking athletes are also
very funny yes and i'm like blake
griffin you don't need this
yes you know you're so good in one area
of your life and then you do this and
i'm like oh
oh you're really quick and funny yeah
this is all i ever had
a little bit of and you know what i mean
i can't dabble in what you're doing
it's irritating well we have a clip here
we have a clip here from the crew
and uh anything we need to do to set
this up i don't
i'm not sure we need anything for it no
i don't think i
know not during covid we don't do setups
during covid
no they were taken away
that's the thing i want when kovid's
over and we all get vaccinated i want
my setups i want setups to come back
all right let's take a look at this clip
from the crew oh
right here you go and our waitress
apologizes ryan bellainey
grabbed your wings off the car before
she picks them up what
son of a [ __ ] ryan blamey
flick me off i think so that's a weird
way to lick your fingers
hey what are you doing we figured you
had enough wings
we just sat down no we mean like in life
oh hey austin i didn't see you there why
don't you hop up on blinny's shoulders
and come in as one person
i'm 5'8 that's average height if you
stand in your helmet yar
that helmet won the daytona 500. i just
want to have one meal without you
bringing that up man
so they sent funny the other and they
have a sense of humor about themselves
too
they do they're really good uh and and
one quick question you had i heard an
audience laughing so that was probably
shot
just pre-coveted are you able to shoot
now
and and how do you how do you work it
out we shot
seven episodes with a live audience
which was fire it was great and then we
had
three we were able to come back and
finish the three
without an audience so that was brutal
because of the energy
you don't you know you you got to keep
it up and you don't realize how much you
fall off without that
live audience well so kevin you're
talking to a guy who built his career on
pity laughs
and so i i i need them very badly
i want to also mention you have a
youtube channel that sounds like a lot
of fun let's get the word out on that
oh yeah yeah it's uh uh this family of
uh
uh brothers uh the canaans uh from from
uh
rhode island actually great great group
of guys they have they kind of
inspired me we were kind of quarantined
together and we all uh we came up with
uh
making a bunch of shorts and just having
some fun and putting some fun out in the
world and uh
that was it it was just it's been a
blast so how do people find it is it
just kevin james youtube kevin james
yeah yeah kevin james youtube
check that out and uh yeah tell them
tell them i said
hello i have uh quasi rhode island roots
i spent a lot of time there as a kid
so we'll do yeah we'll do that's where
all my sun damage comes from uh
the miss kwama cut state beach in rhode
island
that cut years and years off my life uh
all right so check out uh kevin's
youtube channel it sounds really funny
and the crew is streaming now
on netflix uh kevin really nice to talk
to you always a pleasure
and uh you know stay well we'll see you
thank you cody
i appreciate it